ottawa de bras tous les voyageurs
canadiens de revenir au pays le plus
rapidement possible en fait avant que ça
soit plus possible de revenir c'est pas
sans créer de casse tête pour les
voyageurs par an en tout de suite avec
l'autre gagnant qui est en espagne
bonjour monsieur gagnon oui bonjour
alors respect vous êtes à malaga vous
depuis le mois de février la mi février
vous devriez revenir le 21 avril alors
qu'elles sont au plein alors disons
qu'on a modifié mon plan à deux reprises
son de chercher des billets d'avions
alors d'abord une première fois avec les
rebelles
avec pardon l'aide d'art transat c'était
très difficile et très laborieux on ne
riches à avoir deux billets pour le 31
mars
mais compte tenu des circonstances qui
se dégrade au fur et à mesure on a tenté
d'avoir encore d'autres billets et là on
s'est acheté deux autres billets et
cette fois ci pour le 19 mars avec un
départ pour paris et retour au québec
nous l'espérons le 20 mars
bon alors vous avez été dans votre
malchance dans une certaine chance quand
même été assez bien entre temps qu'est
ce que vous voyez vous autour de vous à
malaga le commandant comment comment est
la vie
ben disons que la vie c'est pas
tellement heureuse je peux vous dire
qu'on a reçu un communiqué dernièrement
on dit que c'est l'état d' alerte ici en
espagne qui est cloisonné alors je peux
vous lire ici ce que j'ai reçu depuis
samedi soir les espagnols n'ont plus le
droit de sortir de chez eux sauf en cas
de besoin qu'ils devront justifier aux
forces de l'ordre et militaires
mobilisés pour surveiller le respect du
confinement
alors c'est pour vous dire les extraits
c'est vide il n'y a plus moyen d'aller
dans les restaurants
il ya plus personne qui circule les
autobus ne circule boy pull de transport
donc même les hôpitaux n'arrive plus à
recevoir tout le monde on transforme les
hôtels en hôpital ya 6271 personne de
contaminer actuellement et 189 morts
ouais vous vous vous avez vous dressé un
portrait assez inquiétant qu'est ce que
vous faites de vos journées le rester
vous restez vous rendant toute la
journée
limiter tous vos contacts absolument
mais disons que nous on limite nos
contacts depuis à peu près une semaine
et demie de semaine on évite les
transports en commun parce qu'on ne veut
pas justement être contaminés on veut
absolument quitter le pays
moi j'ai communiqué avec l'ambassade du
canada en espagne
d'abord j'ai pas eu de réponse parce qu'
il est impossible de les rejoindre
on dit que l'ambassade du canada
d'espagne est fermée à cause du coran
d'un virus j'ai eu rejoindre sos canada
lapassade ottawa est ce que j'ai comme
réponse on me dit dépêchez vous monsieur
gagnon a quitté malaga dépêchez-vous a
quitté l'espagne venait de vol le plus
rapidement possible mais des vols n'y en
a plus il ya plus possibilité de quitter
c'est très difficile alors mais nous on
espère qu'il est le 19 mai n'est pas sûr
qu'on quitte le 19 parce qu'on parle de
fermer les aéroports
alors qu'est ce qui arrive oui donc
c'est pas impossible que vous soyez pas
capables que tout soit fermé en espagne
que vous soyez braves de sortir même du
pays
absolument se civiliser inquiète
grandement et on est plusieurs québécois
il faut savoir que les gens qui sont ici
présentement ce ne sont pas de jeunes
personnes ce sont des gens retraités et
beaucoup de gens ont plus de soixante
ouais bah écoutez on va vous garder à
l'oeil comme ça si vous permettez
l'expression
pour voir qu'est ce qui en est parce qu
avec un gros groupes comme ça c'est
effectivement et en plus en allant à
paris mais la france sait guère plus
c'est guère mieux le danois mal alors là
aussi il ya des des complications rabat
vous illustrez bien lol la situation
complexe dans laquelle on se trouve dans
le moment absolument alors nous tout ce
qu'on souhaite ce qu'il y ait des vols
de plus de vols possible le plus
rapidement passé pour nous évacuer d'ici
bas on comprend alors monsieur gagnon
bon courage et on se revoit se tenir au
courant de vos alliés si vous le
permettez et six doubles et interminable
moi je voudrais dire aux canadiens
qu'ils pensent quitter de québec ou le
canada pour aller en voyage ne le fait
pas rester à la maison
message comme propos merci monsieur
gayant
au revoir merci mille